on a scale of one to ten how excited are
you that Trudeau is not our leader we
have the story from the Daily Mail
president XI humiliates Trudeau as he is
caught on camera tearing strips off
Canadian PM that their conversation at
the G20 has been leaked to the papers
it's not appropriate this was the the
most epic cringe I've seen and and let's
be real so in this video Trudeau is
trying to talk to Xi Jinping cameras pop
up and man Trudeau looks weak it looks
like a mouse staring at an elephant Xi
Jinping won't even look at his face
That's how little respect he's giving
him well I get it Canada's a small
nation XI jinping's probably like why is
this guy thinking he can talk to me but
talk about humiliating I know did you
guys see this one yeah it's uh
definitely an example of a language
barrier poor Trudeau the poor guy I mean
he he probably had his socks ruffled
from this interaction that's probably
the most confrontation he got in his
entire life and this is sad for him
mainly because he loves China he talked
about how he adored China being able to
change the economy on the dime he he he
adores what China's doing and is
replicating those same policies inside
of Canada of course imprisoning his
protesters debanking people who dare
speak out against him disarming the
local population there and now of course
offering euthanasia to of course the
poor people there and the depressed
people there who does that what kind of
political leader does that despotic
leaders and when he was looking to see
his his his his his beautiful Overlord
that he wants to replicate all of the
policies he just got smacked down right
in the face and it was it was incredible
to see the body language there because
it said a lot and when G he told him off
you see you see Judo be like I hope you
have peaceful rational discussions in
the future and and then and then G's
like what and then he walks off like
like Forrest Gump it was pathetic it was
sad and it shows you how weak a lot of
these individuals are that do create the
bad times that we have to live through
it's kind of like when someone raises a
pet alligator some people are like I'm
gonna have the most dangerous animals
pet and then one day the animal grows up
and bites him in the leg and like and
they have to euthanize the animal and
you just see that like the disbelief and
sadness in the owner's face like this
can't happen God this guy's Brewing the
monkeys ate that woman's face yeah oh
geez this I feel really bad for Trudeau
I do I I feel a deep sadness it reminds
me of that time that uh I don't I don't
know if this story is true because I'm
having trouble finding Source on it but
it's a Elon Musk was asked about Neil
Armstrong criticizing him and Elon cried
because you know Elon really looked up
to Neil Armstrong had this dream of of
expanding the space program and all that
stuff and to hear you know that one of
your Heroes was mocking or criticizing
you must be so brutal for Trudeau to
finally get to meet his hero only to be
just poo pooed and shoot aside must have
been truly devastating for the man
absolutely what was it exactly that
happened that caused this conversation
did you guys hear like something was
leaked so zoo was mad because they were
supposed to be having private
conversations between them the topics of
those conversation was leaked to the
Canadian press obviously from Trudeau
who didn't keep his word and and
promised to keep conversations secret
and private between the two so this is
also something that Emmanuel macron did
to Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin was
also mad at him because Emmanuel macron
had a documentary film crew recording
some of the conversations that they
thought was Private that they thought
wasn't going to be discussed to the
general public and they were talking
very frankly and this shows you that
Trudeau wasn't a man of his word wasn't
a man of Honor because they agreed hey
what we say here stays between us it
didn't it was leaked to the media by
Trudeau and then Trudeau is like Trudeau
leaked it uh someone in in the Trudeau
Administration if not Trudeau himself
and was like yeah it's not cool I'm
paraphrasing I was like yeah that's not
cool dude and then Trudeau was like we
like to have open dialogue and make sure
and XI Jim who's like buzzle and like
just turns and like walks up like what
is he talking about open dialogue that's
not a concept that I'm familiar with no
I just want someone should take that
that interview of Elon Musk crying and
deep fake Trudeau's face on it and then
have the interviewer ask the question
like you met your hero Xi Jinping and he
was critical of your your efforts how
does it make you feel and he's just like
he really he really cried huh Elon yeah
so that's the story that I read I
remember seeing it a while ago I mean I
actually I feel for Elon in that regard
it was I guess the story was back in uh
uh you know at the beginning of SpaceX
Neil Armstrong was critical of Elon
musk's attempt at a private space uh uh
business and then at some time later
afternoon Armstrong died Elon was asked
about it and Elon apparently a big hero
of his was Neil Armstrong I mean that's
real that's kind of sad absolutely a
little sad I know me too like that's a
big bummer imagine like being a little
kid and seeing something so profound as
a moon landing and space travel and
saying when I grow up I'm Gonna Change
the World and like you look at what
elon's doing now with SpaceX and how
powerful and amazing it is and uh Neil
Armstrong's never going to see that
because he died 10 years ago but but
leaving this world critical of of Elon
that's gotta hurt man yeah you know so I
can understand how Trudeau feels you
know being shunned like this can you
imagine the boot licking that Trudeau is
going to have to do now to get into the
good graces of the Chinese or maybe
he'll maybe he'll snap back oh yeah the
other night um Donald Trump this is last
night referred to Xi Jinping as the king
of China yeah King for life and XI was
like I'm not the king he's like well you
have all the power you're in for life so
basically he's actually a Viceroy this
is when the emperor would designate
someone to become a king for Life
they're actually the Viceroy they don't
have familial
um they can't they can't pass the land
onto their kids upon death yes upon
death it goes back to the Empire and
then the emperor can designate another
viceroidal leaders but there's no
Emperor well there's the CCP is the
party is in control and there's probably
one of them there's a bunch of oligarchs
I think sure sure I think I think I like
Viceroy I wonder if there's a better
word though because the emperor would
determine the Viceroy the vicero die and
then to choose someone else or not or
they would take away right right so it
doesn't have to be if a family thing to
correct anybody
if there's no Emperor no secession rules
with viceroy's if there's no Emperor we
could say Viceroy but maybe there's a
better word for it I just don't know I
mean maybe there's a better word to
describe it's it's not King but you know
Viceroy Viceroy she
yeah it's better than president the
thing about President we talked with the
uh I think I can't remember who we had
on we had some China experts and they
said president is the wrong word uh
chairman beats the correct word right
yeah but then all of a sudden the media
started calling him president for some
reason yeah because they're trying to
normalize it make it seem like they're
trying to equate what he is to our
president who's elected I heard that
they changed the definition of the word
president in China to make it so that
what he was and I don't want to get this
wrong did you hear anything about this
wait did you say Sith Lord yes they
changed the definition of Sith Lord and
they changed the definition of something
this is what I heard about six years ago
so that he could now be literally called
the president and it made sense whereas
like 30 years ago the word meant
something else yeah yeah so so just to
be clear in 2013 Trudeau said that he
most admires China when asked
specifically which country he admires he
said quote there's a level of admiration
I actually have for China because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them to
actually turn their economy around on a
dime and say we need to go green we need
to start you know investing in solar and
then he went on and of course saying
there is flexibility that I know Prime
Minister Stephen Harper who was prime
minister at the time quote must dream
about having a dictatorship where you
can do whatever you wanted that I find
quite interesting that's a direct quote
from Justin Trudeau from 2013. and then
just about 10 years later he meets his
hero and it's disappointing yeah he's
probably balling his little fire you get
burned you know and this happened
publicly so you can imagine what happens
not publicly because you could see Z in
the translator the translator even kind
of moved out of the way when the cameras
were filming so that we could get
Trudeau's face in the interaction that
the translator was aware of the camera
he was like we need this on tape we need
the world to see this so this is what's
happening publicly what's happening
behind the scenes when the cameras
aren't there you could only imagine how
much more Brazen how much more brutal
these politicians are to each other and
I wouldn't be surprised if she went up
to to Trudeau and just slapped him up a
couple times man listen here boy you're
gonna do as I say and she's like yes sir
yes I will yes no problem and I I could
actually see that happening again that's
not my own Theory I could be wrong I
want to do a Winnie the Pooh joke but I
don't know how many people know the
Winnie the Pooh meme about Xi Jinping so
I think they actually pulled what people
thought that he looked like Winnie the
Pooh and there were names of it and then
in China I think they banned Winnie the
Pooh because yeah right yeah yeah and
any mention of it on WeChat and any
photos wow yeah yeah that's the thing
he's he looks happy oh Xi Jinping
actually looks like a really happy
friendly guy when I see his face like I
could laugh it up with him he does he
does the most annoying thing about doing
segments on China is that when I'm when
I'm looking for uh photos of individuals
you can usually see a range of emotion
that uh represents part of the idea so
like if there's a story where it's like
you know Joe Biden
um says X and it's like an angry thing
you could find a picture of Joe Biden
like giving a finger wave with Xi
Jinping it's like Stone and yes Stone
Face on every context it's just a
picture of him and he's just
just flat-faced like dude should play
poker I'd love to see him play Texas
Holdem to be like I can't tell what he
has Putin's similar it's probably
because he's like xkgb it's like do not
show any emotion yeah your job is to
hold all the cards yeah just
compartmental it just
keep it all in but you're right you're
right with Xi Jinping have you seen the
the Montage someone made where it's all
the different handshakes he's given and
the video is going through every photo
really really fast
and all the people are flickering and
changing and she is the exact same
position the whole time through like
hundreds of photos the way his body is
the way his face is the way his hand is
like never changes yeah it's a robot or
something well I bet they practice that
with something because I don't think Joe
Biden he might practice shaking people's
hands but I bet the ccp's choreographed
it like they have like meetings and like
you learn how to present yourself and
how to stand and how to be like
represent tallness sorry sorry quick
question people are saying Elon didn't
cry he almost cried he almost cried yeah
I want to say if he cried if he didn't
he teared up like Rachel Maddow when she
found out Trump didn't clue with Russia
what kind of person you know cheers on
and admires a Chinese dictatorship
a person like Bill Gates who also
admires the Chinese dictatorship who
previously just a couple months ago said
that they were doing a great job with
their zero sickness policy and of course
also does work business with the Chinese
government and uh also uh you know uh
what's it called what does he do
um Works officially uh the thing when
you give someone advice Consulting
Consulting yes sorry all right he
consults the CCP as well thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time